alors le dialogue n'est pas possible et
pauvre mec sort sous la table d'areva ou
alors à temps il ya un truc que je
devrais dire avant de commencer toi
parce que moi je suis un mec est
vachement francs vachement direct toi un
truc que je veux dire c'est pour moi
corneille c'est de la merde
non mais attends tenir penche s'explique
jeudi c'est de la merde parce que bon
premièrement
c'en est un et puis deuxièmement c'est
un truc qui se pose pas sur les poèmes
de jeunes problèmes de couple et tout
bordel toi alors que moi j'ai un copain
c'est dudule tu le connais dudule ah ben
non plus pas le connaître
bon eh ben dudule alors lui il n'est pas
connu comme corneille il n'a pas la
gloire et tout ça ça d'accord à
seulement lui bon premièrement il est
vivant un nom mais déjà au départ ce une
bonne avance et puis deuxièmement il
écrit des trucs tentera pas ce que ça
veut dire
d'ailleurs je vais te dire un de ses
poèmes là là maintenant oui tout de
suite je vais te dire un poème de dudule
à et après je te dirais tant corneille
si tu es sage à on est entre nous ça va
bien se passer et areva ont alors j'y
vais poème d'un copain alors je
t'explique c'est un poème qu'il avait
écrit à cause d'une anna qu'il était
vachement amoureux d'elle toit et la
nana à s'appeler gisèle alors le poème
il avait appelé gisèle toi le bon j'y
vais poème d'un copain dudule enfin
gisèle enfin bon tuer tuer nos femmes et
une mare dur à dire nos merveilleuses
ménagères merveilleuse cuisinière
merveilleuse mère pour les enfants et
pourtant ma petite gisèle c'est toi que
je désire
ah bon tu es mieux tant corneille
ok ok ça va j'ai compris bouge pas très
bien où tu es alors je dis ton truc et
je me casse pauvre tard ils bougent pas
j'y vais quand je regarde auguste au
milieu de sa gloire est une bordel
ala excuse moi je peux pas dire des
trucs comme ça et que vous présentez à
ma triste mémoire mon vieux
mon père excuserait 1 on n'a pas
l'habitude de la maison à massacrer du
trône où je le vois fait le premier
degré et tout le trafic non tu vois je
veux dire moi j'ai déjà vu des trucs
coin parce que bon y'a pas besoin de
sortir beaucoup mais alors à ce niveau
là c'est quand même assez rare a
personnellement je dirais même que c'est
une sorte de record
tu as déjà mis les mecs qui jacte comme
ça ta pauvre tard et tu le vois aller
chercher du boulot en parlant comme ça
dites-moi patron chaumes du direct
quand même pas besoin de passer par
l'emploi tarif 2 e
qu'est ce que tu as tu m'as récent à
rennes 1 1
alors tu n'as pas l'air d'avoir bien
commun je vais te réexpliqué tu vois moi
je suis le genre d'individu je te file
une baffe à deux doigts qui sortent des
pompes tu le sais ça je te souffle
dessus tu attrapes une angine le sait ça
alors lâche mal coup d'une minute et
demie et 30 secondes tu la reverra ta
mère est massacrée joueurs progrès je
m'abandonne tort à vos ardent transpo
mais il a dit au tas
ah bon c'est ça ça va j'ai compris alors
c'est comme partout il y en a qu'on
droit de le dire et puis d'autres pas
c'est ça ok alors t notés toi je te le
dis ta cote monte un je vais déguisée à
la sortie moi tu vas voir le carnaval
voit les bouches partie bien août est
sacrée c'est pour une mort les devoirs
mille morts hier terminé à wimille mort
ils sont morts c'est la fin on va porter
quoi non le réveillon non je te dire un
truc quand même ta cage vraiment du bol
mais vraiment du bol qu'il faut que
j'aille faire porter ma me l'a réparé et
de te dire un truc quand même au passage
c'est que moi je suis un film un
appareil photo et crois moi que la photo
elle est prise 1 il n'ya plus qu'à
développer ainsi un jour on se croise
dans la balle à samedi soir un truc
comme ça quoi bon ça peut arriver à un
accord
alors y'a que les montants qui se
raconte pas tu arrives à toi moi je suis
en train de danser avec magie skate
bourgeois tranquille et toi et toi tu tu
vas même pas le faire exprès c'est ça
qui est terrible
la destinée un tel atari vêtu ma fleur
coup de boule portefeuille terminé à 100
dans le caniveau des trois tours
à la sécu direct ya de la place comme je
t'ai dit gemma meule qui m'attend là bas
derrière mais e1 roma
crois moi quoi m'a pas la chance